all right saying
saying oh were you from origin
originally south korea south korea yeah
you came to the united states when uh
back in 1981
1981 uh i am 51 now so you came over as
a kid i came over when i was uh nine
years old right
tell me about your family
uh i have one brother and i have mother
and father they're all living
and my brother is
his older brother two years older and um
we grew up
we grew up pretty rough
how's that
we fought a lot
and we put each other into hospitals
quite often oh really yeah
when we fought we took it to a new level
it was a real sibling rifle right yeah
it was more of a
rivalry gang style
i would throw them off the second floor
and i'll push him through a window
and he would hit me with a chair metal
chair on my head and he would hit me
with a shovel on my knee
so it was uh
it was rough what do you think it was
based on
competition no no it wasn't that i think
it was uh more of um
we just
we i i think reasons were the same as
regular people but we just took it to a
whole new level i think you guys are
serious yeah
you get along now
uh we talk yeah we do we do in a way we
do anyway but he is very different from
me
so
he's a more of a normie type mm-hmm
and you like to have fun i don't have
fun else i like to be a little loose and
i don't really
i try to judge people
because i believe it's not
what you do is how you do it
and
as long as it does not take over that
person
which in my case few times it has okay
i believe what that person does does not
when one one event does not define the
person
so i mean i i honestly i met a lot of
interesting people here
a lot of interesting people
and people with uh
high education from good families
and with the letters in back of their
names
and but then uh
they're
they're all the same
they're all the same
but we see them differently we see
people on fifth and saint peter are
different with the people and doctor's
office in beverly hills right but if you
really really strip away all the
extra things on the on the side
they're the same we're all still human
they're all same and they're both very
afraid
fear is what drives a lot of us fear is
what drives
yeah majority of them yeah fear is a
very
and there's healthy fear and there's
not healthy fear
but i think the people on the streets
have
i guess uh
more of the non-healthy fears
and the people that are
the normal track of life have healthy
fears and they can differentiate
as to whether
we
we are not able to sometimes
but it's it's but then to make a show i
mean it's been a really interesting um
two years
for you yeah so let's back up to a
little bit how far did you go to school
uh
i
i was in phd down in san diego
and after about three years
uh i
left on a leave of absence
i was uh
yeah
i qualified i know actually i was
advanced candidacy
and i was i was supposed to prepare for
my uh q exam which is a a qualifying
exam
and uh
but i was working at i was working at
ibm at that time and going to school
full-time and teaching two labs for my
advisor
so
i
was spreading myself real thin
and i kind of snapped
i think i kind of snapped
are you was there pressure from your
family to achieve
and i don't want to say like that
because it makes them seem like a
slave driver okay
but in a way that's our culture though
yeah
and we can't fight culture
and then um i mean they
did my mother and father my
god
all they ever did was provide for us
okay
and my mother who's been american now um
so 42 years okay
has not had a chance to step on stepping
to disneyland yet
because when she was a capable
physically
she was always working
and now she's old so she's not
physically capable
so
in a way it's kind of sad
but that's what our culture drives
so
i guess something that we have to live
with
you've been married
yes
once you have kids yes two kids
you how long were you married
i was married the machine
2000
20
so
97
for 23 years 23 years yeah
and you're divorced
yes three years ago you told me yeah
and so since since you've been divorced
you've been uh
picking up girls on the streets
sometimes yeah i mean a man has needs
and i surely do have needs
but then the knees always came with a
price tag and and
i'm talking more
than money
and so uh
yeah
because
to divert myself from looking at
something else
i try to concentrate on something
something that is negligible
something that is menial meaningless i
attach meaning to it so i have to look
at the things that that really has
mean meaning to it
so
yeah yeah yeah i mean in the beginning i
was um
in the beginning i was kind of uh
stupid
but then sometimes i go through maybe
two three
two or three growth a day
yeah
and beginning i had some money
and so it really didn't it
financially i i was stable
and uh
so it was kind of
funny but
there was
nothing would
it's like a
bolt and a
bolt on a screw
it quite fits
but it doesn't go in all the way
so so that's why that's why i went
through so many girls
it's just something was missing
and uh maybe you were looking for a
companion or love
no no because i never really believed in
love
what do you think you're looking for
i think i was trying to
find somebody to
feel me
okay i'm supposed to feel me
but then but that part of me was gone
and i was gonna have somebody else feel
it for me
and they could for maybe hours
but
it was all just smoking mirrors
and so it felt even more emptier
that's why some of the girls that i
have seen uh
they think i'm a little weird
because once that thing hits me
i didn't want to look at them it just
just really
it gets me mad at myself
and so and i believe
that getting angry at somebody else
i always told my kids that's wrong
okay you can get you can get mad but you
can't get angry at somebody else
okay
and so i would i would try to get them
off the course as fast as possible
because i knew myself if i
if i kept looking at them
i would cross the line
and get mad at them there will be a
target
so i i i didn't want that was it guilt
or was it shame or
i guess it's commonest of all but then
mostly it was
it was just
i realized how futile everything was
it's a sad relationship if you really
boil it down yeah you say and uh
stranger she's gonna have sex with you
and yeah and something i didn't have sex
with
yeah sometimes i didn't have that i just
talked for a little bit and i spent two
or three hours or whatever and then i
said you know what yeah yeah i gotta go
now
because at that time uh
i had quite a bit of work
i got uh i was in contracts
and so i was busy and sometimes i'm busy
for three or four days
and i'll relieve the stress on that
but
that started to give me stress
what i was doing to relieve stress
that was the mistress
causing even more stress yeah and uh
because some of these girls are
scandalous
okay
i mean that that and that that stressed
me out
because
when i was younger
uh i've done all the gangsta a lot of
stuff so i mean
i know them
and i see it
yet
because of my
i had that kind of
i would say dark life and then i uh with
help my father i turned it around and
turned it into education
and so i became an engineer
but then that that was my previous life
and then i returned to this
so i still have memories of what i knew
before so i can see the signs
and these girls
but i don't act like i said as if i know
them but then
i mean some of them are really
scandalous
for them
that is all that life is
everything else is optional they're just
trying to survive
no this is true yeah i guess so because
then some of them believe they need a
drug to survive
it's not a physical addiction
because sometimes
they have built so much [ __ ] on
themselves
that they can't stand themselves when
they come to
and they have to have some something to
take them out of themselves
so in that way they need it
but i used to tell the story you don't
need it you want it
you want to skip yourself you don't need
to skip yourself
yeah
when somebody attacks me i need to
protect myself
not that i want to okay
but
when when i want to practice something
like the martial arts i want to practice
it i don't need to
so there's a big difference between need
and a month
so i just tell the ends so some of those
girls used to tell me
you make everything you make everything
is a philosophy
but if a human does not think
that person is not a human
that's what makes us different from
animals
that's why i used to tell some of the
guys the guys that i hang around with it
doesn't matter what they do they think
rob old lady whatever they do okay
but whatever they do
they have to have their rules
if anything goes in any situation
then i will immediate then i will
immediately let them go because that's
very dangerous
so they must have some kind of some kind
some type of constraint
may it may be i mean
something that is meaningless to others
but
yes i still describe that you have to
have lines
if you don't have lines you i mean
you're just an animal
but in some of these girls and guys as
i've seen
they don't have that
are drugs a part of your life oh yeah
yeah i like drugs a lot
do you like what i like drugs a lot you
do yeah and you've been using
what's your favorite uh mainly cocaine
correct crack yeah and that's been going
on for how long
april of 1989 was when i first used
cocaine okay
then
when i took my first hit of crack
cocaine
in on june 19th of 1989 i will never
forget that day
because on that day
i asked myself
where the [ __ ] have you been
i mean it was
it was
complete
all the noise that went away
and i was in total silence
and it was it was beautiful it was
wonderful
i could
actually
rest
but then i even i never knew
it would grow grow into this monster
that i
have to face
but
as
my therapist told me
mr lee you made the bed
you can't
keep running from it you have to lay it
someday
you have to
or somebody will leave there in a coffin
okay so
don't run he said
yeah since i was always
always all these quote unquote
achievements
i was running from something
because it was either
that
or crack
and nothing
i i really didn't do anything that i
really enjoyed
leisurely
i i don't think i even know what the
word leisure means
you're always working
yeah it's always
finishing something finishing something
that's what i like to learn
because not that i can i not that i can
boast
i don't really both because if i know
that i'm uh what i am i don't convince
anybody else
but
for the time that i'm learning
my brain is like
70 on that topic and i i i'm totally
submerged in it
so for that moment that is the only
noise i hear
all the noise falls in the background
and that's why i like it i think
and that's why
they have told me that i'm a great
student
that i have a great
ability to concentrate
you have to run
i don't know what i'm running from but
i have to run some days
and
i really honestly i mean i mean after
all the therapist hours
i still don't know what that is
that i'm running from
and i feel that if i don't find out soon
that's gonna kill me
and i'll be okay too though
at least i have total silence
so
incredibly
i went through all the schooling okay
while using drugs while using crack and
your jobs as well yeah wait what kind of
jobs have you had what was your name
what was your main career
my
my main career of my last career was
with ibm
and uh
i was a research r d person
for their design kits
so
so to make a long story short ibm makes
hardware
and people who want to build hardware
engineers have to have software to build
those on the computer okay so what's
physical must match what is digital
i i used to be the i used to do what
they call modeling of the physical
device into a
digital model that they can use in their
circuits of designers
so
that was my last job
and then ever since then i kind of
straight off my main
education path
and i started the computer networks
because while i was doing my uh
masters
i had to take care of my own computer
because school didn't have the funding
for me so they gave me the computer
workstation but i had to learn unix i
have to learn networking i mean i had to
do it on my own you're still working
i now i don't
work
so when i want to and i can go and and
apply for contracts
contracts that seem interesting like for
example
like best buy
about
six months ago
nationwide all best buy
uh
access points have been swapped out from
cisco to aruba
or ruba is a company
that's bought by uh
i believe hewlett packard okay
so i mean i don't know the
story behind it but so they would have
this contrast up there so each best buy
would require two texts okay and about
12 hours to swap out all the aps okay
access points of the wi-fi
and so i would apply to that and then if
they feel that i have enough credentials
or i have enough experience they will
give it to me
and so those jobs will uh bringing
bringing about 800 800 to 1000 a night
okay but that will be
yeah so those are the type of work that
i'll apply for i mean it's not as
lucrative as that is okay sometimes i
will drive
round trip
five hours and maybe work for
two hours
at 80 an hour so that 160 it seems like
a lot
but plus the five hour driving and the
gas
so i
so my actual profit comes out about 20
bucks an hour
so
sometimes
i believe in life in everything even
drug trades yeah
i i just joke to my
people to deal with and sometimes you
sometimes me
you can't always come on
you can always come out on top yeah
how often will you go down to pick up
some of the girls
the beginning
i will stay sometimes i would just stay
there i would just go to the one going
to stay there and just get high a little
bit and pick up another one all day
every day
in the beginning yeah
uh the days are the days that i was not
at work
because sometimes i uh
some projects would be like
uh two-day work
so i couldn't
come here
for the for the two days what is your
favorite thing about these girls
everything
someone did some of them do
uh oral sex great
but then the sex part is not the part
that really interests me
it's uh
i hate it at the same time i am amazed
by it
it's the acting skills
it really is
i mean some of them are like
academy award-winning style
okay
i mean
yeah that's the part that really
appalls me at the same time really
really interests
they
me they didn't take any acting class
they learned on a on a need
and some of these girls i mean
you could
the government should hire them for
spies okay
you could put them up you could put them
in a light sector okay i guarantee you
the passive okay
when you can
shed real tears okay
after smoking crack with me for like two
hours okay real tears let me still under
influence partially
when you want to
i
for me
that's not even possible that's even
thinkable
i found out that uh sometime afterwards
that the whole thing was a lie
it was skit
yeah
but i mean they they gained some
monetary gain
but after i found out that oh well you
know
i don't see him anymore
so because have you ever developed
feelings for any of these girls that you
oh yeah
one of them
but then uh
the whole
i mean i still do have feelings for that
person
about i said for that imaginary person
because the person that i have feelings
for does not exist
okay
your imagination created what you wanted
it is a
fueled by what she was saying and doing
and that was uh i think 99 lies if not
100
yeah but i do give
before the doubt one percent you got to
remember these these girls are hustlers
first yeah they're hustlers but then um
you see high house
sometimes the house are too okay
but when the house comes to an end
all tools need to be put down
but some of these girls know
so i think sometimes
this particular girl
i don't think she knows who she is
she's been so she's put on so many masks
okay
she knows who she is
and to be honest
the saddest thing is that i don't think
she cares
because the crack
keeps it going yeah was were you doing
this during your marriage
oh yeah
is that what ended the marriage
to be honest
but
if i be honest yes
my wife they put up a good fight
to uh
hold onto marriage but i try to hold on
to the crack and the marriage
and and the school
and the job
and the hobby
and the extracurricular
education i was doing because i love to
learn
i love to learn
because learning
takes me out of here
takes me out of
the really
the reality
but then uh the
messed up thing about drugs and that and
whatever it is is that
it has all come to an end
i mean i tried to make it last forever
one time i stayed up nine days smoking
crack while i was doing my phd
i was a mess
back then
but then that was the most prosperous
time of my life
but if i looked at it but if i look back
i was i i was a total mess i was wrecked
yeah it's a miracle is there such a
thing as a functional addict
no if you're not if you're an addict no
the people
who do drugs are not all addicts
i've seen people i've smoked with people
who come
by like biogram
and just
we talk and we'll smoke and you get a
call
hey hey hey hey lee i gotta go man right
here oh no you keep that i'm good
walk away and
that wasn't an act
because
you can tell you can tell that something
has no meaning to them
and this crack had no meaning to them
it was just a activity they did like
playing
this track took to backseat to golfing
to them
so
i mean so then that person had an act
but if
you're an addict
that means you're using for a reason
for a purpose
okay then i don't need to function
because some part of your life
will malfunction
i mean you could probably put up a good
facade
maybe keep a career maybe build a career
but there will be a
facet in your life
that's in shambles
you you probably try to cover it up with
all all the other bright things
but but that darkness will be there do
you regret getting involved in drugs
yeah yeah i do i think i do
i i i
i never said it before
but i do
if it wasn't for drugs then it's not the
missed opportunity
missed cal tech phd
he's none of that
but a lot of her less people
yeah
that's
what i regret
he's saying what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
all of this
in steroid or drug either one
the whole lifestyle
drugs prostitution
debauchery
what seems to be
is almost never real
okay
and
my father told me this
he told me are you an idiot
if it sounds too good to be true son
it probably isn't true
because
i loved craig
he took me to a place where i could be
by myself and
i was just kind i was complete
but
i was never complete
so if i was to give advice
crack does not fill the spot
it
basically
replaces you
with emptiness
so the little emptiness you had
will grow into a vast
emptiness where you will not see any any
of you in india no more
so drug is never the answer
but whatever you just have to deal with
is not as bad as you have to deal with
uh
with drugs
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story
i wish you the best of luck thank you
very much
you